[Música]
quienes quieren que el mundo cambie por
favor delante en la mano
me alegra ver tantas manos levantadas
hago esta pregunta porque quiero
comentarles que entre los principales
responsables del calentamiento global se
encuentran los desechos de las empresas
la producción de combustibles fósiles y
los sistemas de transporte pero el
principal responsable del calentamiento
global actualmente
es la ganadería
la ganadería es el responsable del 60
por ciento de la deforestación en el
mundo
durante estos 30 segundos que hablaba
con ustedes han desaparecido el planeta
cinco estadios de fútbol en bosques para
dar paso a pastizales cultivos de maíz y
de soya para alimentar el ganado
convencional esto ha hecho que también
la ganadería sea uno de los principales
responsables de la extinción masiva de
especies modernas y también de la
acidificación de los océanos en el mundo
la ganadería es responsable del 18 por
ciento del total de emisiones de gases
de efecto invernadero inducidas por el
hombre esto es más que la generada por
todos los carros aviones barcos y todos
los sistemas de transporte alrededor del
mundo y casi que el doble que la
generada por la producción de
combustibles fósiles
y si las cosas continúan así para el año
2050 vamos a necesitar de 34 planetas
para saciar la demanda de recursos
naturales que nuestro sistema de vida
tiene
no existe planeta y tampoco planetas
pero la solución para este planeta la
encontré hace algunos años durante mis
investigaciones posdoctorales y desde
entonces he venido trabajando por traer
una solución real y sostenible a los
problemas de seguridad alimentaria y
también de las carnes convencionales
ahora quiero preguntarles cuántos de
ustedes comieron los mini cupcakes que
estaban hace un momento en el descanso
en la mesa de acá atrás
bueno pues realmente estos mini cupcakes
estaban hechos de harina de grillo
yo sé que a muchos les puede sorprender
y probablemente se están preguntando en
este momento como así con harina grillo
pues es justamente lo que hacemos en
nuestra empresa ahora pues es una
empresa que nace como un sueño un sueño
que se ha venido haciendo realidad con
el objetivo de generar una alternativa
proteica a las carnes convencionales y
esto lo hacemos a partir de grillos y no
lo estamos haciendo solos estamos
involucrando nuestra cadena de valor a
mujeres reales para convertirlas en
micro empresarias dueñas de granjas de
grillos porque los grillos no es la
proteína del futuro los grillos es la
proteína del presente hay que hacer clic
y hacer realidad tantos sueños que
queremos ver en este mundo porque para
producir un kilogramo de carne de res
que es lo equivalente a 8 hamburguesas
se requieren 30 mil litros de agua
ese es el agua que cada uno de ustedes
gasta durante todo un año tomando más de
5 minutos mientras que producir la misma
cantidad de proteína pero con grillos se
gastan 27 mil peces menos esa cantidad
de agua
producir un kilogramo de carne de res
genera tantas emisiones como conducir un
carro durante 67 kilómetros producir la
misma cantidad de proteína pero con
grillos se generan hasta 100 veces menos
estas emisiones no les estoy diciendo
que nos vuelvan a comer una hamburguesa
ni tampoco que son vegetarianos pero sí
que al menos comiencen a concientizarse
de que sustituir el consumo de carnes
rojas al menos una vez a la semana por
la harina de grillos le puede ahorrar
mucho al planeta por ejemplo si una
familia de cuatro personas decidiese
incluir en su dieta una vez a la semana
la harina de grillos le podría llegar a
ahorrar el planeta 650 mil litros de
agua
ya que vemos todos los beneficios que
trae desde el punto de vista
medioambiental la harina de grillos
desde un punto vista nutricional también
supera enormemente a la carne de res por
ejemplo tiene nueve veces más cantidad
de calcio tres veces más cantidad de
proteína 12 veces más cantidad de hierro
mucha más vitamina b12 zinc fibra omega
3 y omega 6
la harina de creyó no tiene tantas
grasas saturadas como la carne de res y
tampoco usamos antibióticos y hormonas
durante la producción es muy fácil de
usar pueden hacer un batido pueden hacer
una arepa pueden hacer cualquier tipo de
pararía o repostería e incluso también
pueden hacer una hamburguesa
ahora me gustaría preguntarles a
aquellas personas que si les gustaría
cambiar sus hábitos alimenticios que si
quieren pasar aquí al frente una persona
a comerse una hamburguesa de harina de
grillo
bueno espero que
si están porque se realmente tiene una
mezcla de vegetales y también de harina
de grillo y da la misma cantidad de
proteína que una porción de una
hamburguesa de 125 gramos y esto es una
alternativa que es mucho más viable y
sostenible
muchas gracias
nadie quiere pensar que será de nosotros
y en nuestros hijos en el año 2050 así
que la próxima vez que vean una harina
de grillo o cualquier alimento basados
en insectos en los supermercados espero
que en ese primer salto y sean
conscientes que adquiriendo ese tipo de
productos no sólo están adquiriendo
salud para ustedes para sus seres
queridos pero también para este planeta
ahora me gustaría preguntarles cuántos
de ustedes les gustaría incluir la
harina de grillos en sus dietas por
favor levanten la mano
bueno muchas más manos se levantaron el
mundo no cambia con las historias
el mundo cambia con las acciones de las
personas que hacen historia
el mundo cambia haciendo clic muchas
gracias
[Música]